holy legs mama oh thank you
tell me about picking this dress I put
it on and I was like yep and ya love it
it's it's just different so tell me what
it means not only to be one of the most
successful and I have the show but to be
part of history tonight on the final
broadcast ever um it's very bittersweet
today it is the end of an era I guess
and more than anything I think it's just
wonderful in nostalgia
I think here today there are any judges
critiques from your time on the show
that's stuck with you in your career I
mean I think I think more than anything
the critiques were a learning process
because I'm criticized on a daily basis
so it was kind of the beginning of
learning what that was gonna feel like
and how to handle it and getting used to
it I guess kind of creating a thick skin
any advice learn everything you can be
nice to everybody because you see these
people that work on the show I see them
everywhere at every award show at
everything everywhere so be nice and
learn because it is an it's an
opportunity you know and you gotta just
soak it all up so you can try to try to
make a career after the show's over